I want to tell you about three of my
friends first there's Laura she loves
astrology she's a Scorpio and reality TV
especially the show survivor once when
she knew I was sad she mailed me four
pints of my favorite ice cream across
the country overnight and dry ice
then there's Joanna a fellow engineer
who loves to whine with me about the
worst parts of work when we went to
Arizona together she became so concerned
that I would get dehydrated that she
bribed me to finish my water bottle with
a bag of donuts and then there's Arthur
a late night philosopher who is always
the first person to brave the cold in
Boston when we had all been out for a
late night of drinking and needed some
food we all have these people in our
lives but how do you know who your
friends really are for me it was trauma
that made the lines in my community
really clear two of these people are
still among my best friends and the
third not someone I choose to interact
with anymore so about that trauma it was
the summer between my sophomore and
junior year of college and we were
celebrating graduation when a classmate
raped me but this talk is not really
about him or that night it's about
everyone else and what happened
afterwards it's about you
when I first started telling people
about what happened I was scared
he was friends with everybody so why
would they believe me but I quickly
found that actually everybody believed
me
in fact they were even really surprised
I got a lot of euphemisms in response
like I knew he had had some issues with
women and one person told me that his
freshman year of college he had broken
his hand twice punching walls while
drinking on some level they all already
knew we all of these people in our
communities as well so why do we keep
inviting them to parties what did my
three friends do
in the aftermath once they knew well a
couple years later I was walking to work
and I saw an article in a new site
online about my college dorm community
it prominently quoted my rapist talking
about how he felt free to be himself in
this culture this article was glowingly
reposted by many people who knew
including arthur and joanna i used to
tell people I wasn't trying to get them
to pick a side his versus mine it felt
like the polite fair answer one that
allows for complexity and redemption as
if this was just a bad breakup and I'm
the one who's already moved on but it is
not that and I know what I really want
were none of my friends to talk to him
ever again or elevate his thoughts on
social media I don't want to see his
company on my colleges website I want it
to be illegal for well-meaning
progressives to post diatribes online
decrying a culture that allows Brett
Kavanaugh to prosper even as they remain
friendly and cordial with the Brett
Cavanaugh's in their own community
whenever a rapist is in the noose
whether it's mine or Ben Roethlisberger
I want rape in the headline for how long
maybe forever maybe just until I stop
feeling angry definitely at least a
little bit longer
Arthur deleted his post after I publicly
commented on his support of a rapist he
briefly apologized and then went on to
do something very similar only a couple
months later we do not talk anymore
Joanna deleted her post as well as I
told her how betrayed I felt she asked
how could she be forgiven for something
that felt unforgivable to me she would
ask again crying that night in my
apartment and again a month or two later
as she told me all the things she loved
the most about our friendship
I didn't really have an answer for her
then only that I hoped things would be
okay again
someday not everyone gets a second
chance but then again so many people
don't even ask for one they're not
willing to live with the discomfort of
knowing that they hurt someone they care
about long enough to make it right
meanwhile Laura in true Scorpio fashion
went on what she calls a rampage
she took to Twitter under her public
profile and real name not her burner
account where she posts her hot takes
about Survivor and shredded the article
the people reposting it and the
community norms that make it all
possible
years later when I'm feeling low I still
look for that tweet because I want
people to pick my side even when it
doesn't come for free when I was writing
this talk I wanted to give you a process
or a framework I'm an engineer and a
pilot and I like structure checklists
fail safes
a technical fix will keep us safe
because the alternative is one I tell
you how angry I am and I ask you to be a
little bit braver to deal with a little
bit of sacrifice and discomfort so that
we don't get hurt the truth is I can't
trust you to do that because the
evidence I've seen in my life so far is
that most people will not stand up but I
can't think of any framework that will
protect us if you're not willing to be
brave and have a backbone for your
friends do this early and often because
it is a muscle that needs to be
exercised my own journey with this began
not long after the rape when I was a
baby engineer and my first real
engineering job I was sitting at lunch
with my co-workers eating the same deli
sandwich I had every single day and we
were talking about what we like to do on
the weekends when my coworker James said
sometimes what we love to do is just
drive around town and yell things out
the window out the prostitutes like hey
you're pretty I heard laughter
and the sound of the conversation moving
on as I said nothing and felt anger and
shame the next day I sat at lunch same
people same sandwich and waited tense
for an opening in the conversation and
when one didn't come I jumped in
swinging anyway does he know what it's
like for a marginalized person to be
yelled at by random men in a car it was
awkward and ugly and way too late and
not exactly what I wanted to say but
still I felt avenged and none of them
ever said anything like that in front of
me again I want you to be Elora or a
Johanna speak up no matter how
imperfectly live with the discomfort and
complexity and make sure the people
around you know where you stand when I
heard my co-workers say something that I
thought was not right I did what had to
be done the question is what will you do
[Applause]
[Music]